qu'il est bon de ne rien faire et est de
rêver en respirant le bonheur pur de
l'îlot z'enfants désunir
azimi oui tu as pas te voilà enfin
qu'est ce que ça aille assez vous
facteurs excuse moi juste déranger non
non pas du tout vous avez un peu troublé
ma rêverie je respirais au jeu je tends
nuit non non je n'arrive jamais à momy
moi même alors je ne vois pas comment
vous pourriez y arriver
pour sûr ça c'est bien ça tu as du
caractère quasi mis un aa c'est bien ou
c'est pas bien le caractère et bien
c'est bien quand on a bon caractère et
c'est mal quand on a mauvais caractère
mais pour sûr tu as du caractère tu fais
ce que tu veux
pour ce roi quand j'ai envie de manger
un bon gloubiboulga je le sais alors
l'on casimir soit un petit peu sérieux
j'ai une lettre pour toi c'est sûrement
en admirateur kim écrit pour me dire que
je le fais beaucoup rire peut-être bon
casimir il faut que je te laisse moi je
ma tournée a continué allez à bientôt
à bientôt bonne tournée au c'est une
lettre demande de mon cousin théodule
oui oh là il me dit qu'il est parti en
voyage on le pauvre oui il faut que je
fasse quelque chose pour lui
j'ai une idée françois françois retrouvé
quasiment que ce talent t-il
j'en voudrais à un ballon s'il te plaît
merlo pied c'est pour toi
non non c'est pour envoyer à mon cousin
théodule qui est en voyage à tiens
celui-ci est magnifique
la couleur est très belle dit aux
patrons la couleur n'a pas d'importance
le ballon non plus d'ailleurs mais alors
casimir tout comme la chanteuse a écouté
je te lâche ex dans le pays alors tu
n'as pas besoin de poser question un bon
c'est juste je monte casino on sait
combien un franc cinquante et coutumes
mettra ça sur maintenant qu'à pousser
bien que je n'ai pas de punch comme
d'habitude au fait que tu n'as pas vu le
facteur ainsi il vient de partir par la
part la bombe et je vais essayer de
rattraper parce que j'attends d'un
catalogue
il a dû oublier de le porter d'accord
julie puis julien casimir je lis écoute
je voudrais rien ça va tu sais je n'ai
plus aucune de ces friandises favorite
meilleur tu as la mélasse ni caramel au
point les chardons ou quatre épices et
sans parler de gloubiboulga je n'ai plus
rien en ce moment même mais non je ne
veux pas quelque chose à manger
pardon ah oui oui c'est justement
les clés les dix minutes de la journée
pour je n'ai pas envie de manger car la
chance non je voudrais une grosse caisse
ça tu veux jouer de la grosse caisse
dans l'orchestré l'île aux enfants mais
non je voudrais une grosse caisse en
bois et ben écoute ça tombe très bien
j'ai là justement la caisse de ma
dernière livraison de poupée qui
m'encombre la voilà quelle est la plus
ouverte que françois lucas c'est en
ouvrant au 5 janvier
ça ne fait rien ça fera parfaitement la
faire qu'est ce que tu veux en faire on
raconte julie je te débarrasses beauté
vieille caisse alors ne pose pas de
questions je n'ai pas le temps merci
julie au revoir à monter il faut que je
range ses poupées voilà que les maîtres
la place j'essaie beaucoup de place moi
je vais leur mettre dans la question
c'est que je suis bugs mais il a donné à
casimir il faudrait quand même que je me
décide un jour avoir un peu d'ordre
vous ne trouvez pas c'est parfait il
rentre juste dedans on dirait que cette
caisse a été fait pis y allemand pour
mon ballon mon excellente amie d'aignan
représentants des glorieux casimir us
mon brave mon estime et compagnons en un
mot comme en cent membres à casimir je
te dis bonjour c'est parfait en largeur
aussi ça va très bien
casimir je te fait l'honneur de te
présenter mes salutations il faut que tu
me rendre la politesse
quoi qu'est ce que ça arrête je suis
désolé d'avoir à me répéter casimir et
je te prie de m'en excuser
mais les circonstances me contraignent
j'attends vous attendez c'est une très
bonne occupation au maillot du snop
continuer mais vous attendez quoi rond
juste un jour à je viens de te donner
mes civilités il faut que tu me rendes
mes salutations à vos salutations mon
bac ce sera vite fait un salut
c'est tout ah bon dit que gémir la
discrétion n'est pas un défaut qui
l'habite mais j'aimerais savoir ce que
tu fais je suis en train d'emballer un
ballon gonflé dans une caisse en bois il
emballe un ballon jouent le jeu ni
parler souvent par la bouffe des êtres
ce pas merveilleux
c'est bling tous les ballons du monde
voyage et donc le serait pas rentable
simon vais me retirer afin de méditer
sur cette époustouflante vision adieu
casimir
au revoir monsieur du ce nombre enfin il
me reste plus qu'à mettre le couvercle à
wimille n'y a pas de couvercle org
c'est bien q moi il me faudrait deux
trois petites planches
oh j'ai une idée
[Musique]
oui
tu
[Musique]
oui oui
bon comment commencer la coupe 1 en long
en large ou alors en travers et si mes
repères et tous mes cases in east arrête
moi mon vieux mais qu'est ce que tu
entraînes faire mais ça ne se voit pas
mais si ça ne se voit que tu trouves tu
veux couper cette un voile est alors
qu'ils ont fait ils n'ont pas le droit
françois connais tu as un autre moyen de
se procurer des planches des plonge et
bien il faut aller chercher je sais pas
quoi te répondre moi je mets j'appelle
les autres os pour eux julie monsieur
dix neuf facteurs vite venez wimille et
où je venais des caisses qui a tué la
catastrophe et vous aurez besoin d'être
je suis là
de quoi s'agit-il eh bien casimir veut
ni plus ni moins couper cet arbre
expliquez-lui vu mes amis pourquoi il ne
doit pas le faire moi pour une fois chez
pire nous sommes enfin casimir il ne
faut pas la nature
tu trouves pas que c'est beau un homme
mort celui là c'est le plus beau dit
d'autres enfants moi je suis tu coupes
s'attarde à l'ombre de quoi forger ma
sieste mois casimiro ne coupe pas un
arbre en pleine force de l'âge comme
celui ci en tout cas il ne gêne pas la
croissance d'un autre petit arbre quand
on coupe un arbre c'est qu'il est malade
alors oui c'est très triste d'ailleurs
on le remplace tout de suite par un
jeune homme
je ne voulais pas lui faire beaucoup de
mal je voulais seulement coupé deux ou
trois petites planches mais tu sais
casimir une simple blessure que tu es un
arbre
ah ben je te les donnerait vote et
plonge - il y en a plein au bureau de
poste un bon beh oui ta caisse casimir
on entre là moi que je prenne les
mesures au moins vous êtes gentil
facteur venez venez je vais vous la
montrer
[Musique]
voilà voilà six mois mais c'est un
ballon qui est là nous dans cette pièce
ah oui lorsque le règlement des postes
l'interdît ah non non pas du tout mais
mais un petit paquet vendu reviendrait
moins cher plutôt que cette caisse
ah oui si j'envoyais le ballon dégonflé
mais moi je l'envoie gonflé ouais c'est
pour mon cousin qui théodule qui dents
dans un pays où il s'ennuie beaucoup
et tu crois que ce ballon va le
distraire annoncé lors du net n'est plus
un enfant donc le ballon non mais ce qui
est à l'intérieur
enfin casimir pour sûr à l'intérieur il
n'y a rien enfin rien que de l'air on va
justement voilà
regardez je vais vous montrer vous lire
le passage de la lettre de mon cousin
il me dit je suis dans un pays où il ya
beaucoup de brouillard je t'envie de
respirer le bon air de l'île aux enfants
ah je comprends casimir ton cousin
théodule des fera le neveu du ballon et
pour sûr
alors il respire a soudain le bonheur de
l'île aux enfants
il fermera les yeux et il verra élevé
julie il verra les enfants le verra la
15 heures poules
il verra le kiosque il verra la mer oui
mais il ya aussi le principal dont vous
n'avez pas parlé mais non on n'a pas
oublié casimir avait alors dit là il
verra quasi
pas moi